in the opening scene we see a man named
Damien nocki arriving at a secret drug
manufacturing warehouse to see his
gangster boss the boss visibly upset
discloses the presence of a black sheep
within the gang Damen tries to act
Innocent but the boss has uncovered his
real identity of being an undercover
police agent finding himself caught he
quickly grabs a gun of one of the
henchmen and starts firing with his
professional combat skills he manages to
defeat the entire gang including the
boss however the dying boss tells him
that when he learned about his identity
he traced down his wife as well
terrified of the implication Daman
rushes back home only to discover that
the place is in complete disarray and
his wife has been tragically killed in
the next scene we are introduced to
Simon makoi a history teacher at a high
school he is very concerned about his
students as a rampaging addiction to
drugs has been holding a tight grip over
the whole school turns out that someone
close to the school area has been
selling extremely addictive synthetic
drugs to the students and getting them
hooked on it one morning Simon notices
that one of his students hasn't shown up
for a few days in a row at the same time
his son Camille who studies in the same
class receives a phone call from the
missing boy's mother he gets to know
that the boy has tragically overdosed on
drugs realizing that the situation is
gone too far Simon calls his close
friend who is none other than Daman in
order to request his help how however
the ladder doesn't pick up the call as
he isn't doing well ever since his wife
died he has even quit his job as a
special agent and only spends his days
getting drunk at home but when he hears
his friend's voice message about
something urgent he decides to pay him a
visit at his place as they meet for
dinner Simon explains everything about
the problems that the school is facing
while Camille Eaves drops on the
conversation despite learning the
seriousness of the situation Daman
refuses to help because he's consumed by
his own struggles afterwards he goes to
a grocery store to buy more alcohol but
he's confronted by three Thugs who try
to steal his wallet at first he asks
them to return it politely but when the
thugs refuse to comply he beats the crap
out of them before retrieving it on the
other hand Simon takes matters into his
own hands and sneaks out of his house to
visit a warehouse where he suspects the
illegal drugs are produced but as soon
as he reaches the door he is caught
red-handed by the gang members the
following day Daman awakens to
distressing news on television Simon was
discovered dead in the warehouse the
scenario is set in such a manner that he
is framed as a drug dealer who posed as
a teacher and distributed illicit
substances at the school overwhelmed by
guilt and remorse for not helping Simon
Damien visits his home and tries to
offer consolation to his grieving wife
after living in guilt for some days
Damien finally vows to step back into
action and clear his friend's name from
the criminal accusations with the help
of his past colleague at the police
police force Damen prepares some fake
documents and applies for a job as the
new history teacher on the very day of
his appointment with the school
principal the working staff at the place
try to discourage him from taking up the
job citing its bad reputation their
conversation is soon interrupted by
principal leek who hires him because he
is the only applicant he also ensures
daman's safety in the school asserting
that he has hired a private security
team to prevent the smuggling of drugs
after a brief conversation he calls one
of the teachers Agata kirka and
instructs her to show Damian around from
the following day onward Damian assumes
the role of a teacher but the students
display unruly Behavior despite this he
doesn't fall for their taunts and even
seizes their phones to put them in their
places one of the students frog face is
so adamant that he doesn't obey his new
teacher as a result a leader of the
school security chsky is summoned to
escort him out of the class on the way
Agata tells chamski to report the boy to
the principal after school Agata heads
to her car to drive back home in the
parking lot she's unexpectedly
intercepted by frog face and is boys
seeking
Revenge says frogface but before they
can assault her Damien and another
teacher named Harry arrive at the scene
Daman then gets into hand-to-hand combat
with the boys and defeats all of them
effortlessly witnessing his comrades
being overpowered frogface runs away in
fear in the aftermath Agata expresses
gratitude to Damian for rescuing her and
becomes curious about his background she
thinks it was sweet the way that he just
beat a bunch of student ass however he
evades the question by teaching her some
self-defense techniques later the thugs
bring frogface to Yaro one of the many
students involved in drug smuggling at
school a few moments later their leader
also arrives at the scene in a full
Racers outfit he removes his helmet and
mask revealing himself to be none other
than camil ski and he was not wearing
that helmet because he he was too
handsome to handle here it's revealed
that his security company is just an
excuse to have his men inside the school
both Yaro and shilsky are angry at
frogface for his misbehavior they punish
him emphasizing the Potential Threat to
their illicit operations had he been
caught the next day at school all the
teachers are watching the footage from
the parking lot and praising daman's
combat prowess even though assaulting
students is totally illegal this raises
chil's suspicion towards Daman and he
asks him about his identity but the
latter sticks to his story of being a
history teacher following this he goes
to the classroom only to discover that
the security footage has leaked to the
students as well thus they flood a
series of questions regarding his skills
and also ask him to teach them some
moves this strikes Daman with an idea to
refresh the students mood so he takes
all of them to the basketball court for
fun he forwards a deal if they beat him
there will be no final exam obviously
the students don't get to land even one
hit but they at least enjoy the
experience shortly after Camille shows
up but leaves upon realizing Daman is
the new history teacher seeing this
Damian follows him and confides that
he's here to prove Simon's innocence the
boy reacts angrily arguing that his
father would be alive if he agreed to
help him earlier Daman accepts his
mistake and reveals that he's also
living with the same guilt their
conversation eventually ends in peace
and Camille agrees to help Daman in this
Mission later in the evening Agata who
has developed attraction towards Damian
approaches him and invites him for a
drink during their time in a bar they
notice a group of local thugs harassing
a couple of girls Damen intervenes
urging the thugs to leave the girls
alone however instead of heeding the
warning the thugs charge towards him
leading to a physical confrontation
since these guys are drunk Daman plays
around with them instead of beating them
quickly putting a smile on agata's face
violence is so hot afterwards she
invites him to her place to spend more
time together as soon as they arrive
they start kissing until Agata goes to
the kitchen to grab some drinks in that
moment Damian is suddenly flooded by the
memories of his deceased wife causing
him great discomfort unable to cope he
walks away abruptly without informing
Agata leaving her upset in the next
scene Amelia finds her friend buying
drugs so she tries to warn her just then
Yaro interrupts their conversation and
has his guys grab Amelia Camille steps
in to help but ends up getting assaulted
by the gang a short while later Daman
arrives at school and greets Agata but
the latter treats him coldly keeping
their relationship limited to
professional recently murdered wives are
no excuses for Agata later in class
Damen notices Camille's face covered in
bruises when questioned the boy simply
pretends that he fell and got hurt our
hero doesn't believe this and inquires
with the class but nobody dares to speak
up against Yaro this makes him feel bad
so he decides to help by training them
with combat and self-defense techniques
he then asks everyone to come to his old
Dojo which is currently in a messed up
state in just a couple of days they
clean up the entire Place making it
ready for use as days pass by Daman
dedicates extra effort to his history
classes and training sessions
simultaneously keeping a watchful eye on
the gang members amidst this he also
manages to locate the place where the
gangsters store their drugs and
anonymously tip off the police but
unbeknownst to him schilsky is observing
his actions covertly one day after the
training session Damen stays in the dojo
for personal training during this a
bunch of masked men walk into the place
and launch their attack despite being
more in numbers they are unable to
overpower Daman who ends up defeating
them the following day Damen notices
chil's security members bearing bruises
on their faces which makes him realized
that they were the ones behind the masks
last night from a distance Yaro tells
shilsky that he has an idea to get rid
of Damien and prevent further
interference with their business on that
very night Yaro along with his
associates breaks into Amelia's house
and asks her to collaborate with them in
framing Damian when she refuses he grabs
her by the hair and threatens to kill
her father ultimately making her agree
the only trap Daman can't escape is a
Honey Trap the next morning Damen
arrives at the school to find the
teachers and students gathering in the
hallway in an unexpected turn of events
Les accuses Damien of sexually molesting
Amelia during the training session as a
result the principal suspends him from
work until the case gets solved Daman
tries to explain himself but the
security team ushers him out of the
building this results in a loss of trust
among the school Community with many now
viewing Damian as an abuser the most
disappointed person is Camille who vents
his anger on him for breaking his trust
after this Amelia is so overwhelmed with
the guilt that she falls back into her
old addiction of consuming drugs later
that evening Damen pays her a visit to
know why she did so Amelia doesn't
hesitate to reveal the truth saying that
she was threatened by Yaro this
Revelation makes him feel bad as well
but before he can talk more her father
walks in and throws him out in anger
afterwards Damien goes to see frog face
who is currently admitted to the
hospital he tries to persuade the boy to
help him in exposing the drug dealers
also citing that the gangsters will no
longer accept him back frogface who
feels betrayed by the gang eventually
discloses that the drugs aren't brought
into the school but are rather produced
inside after he delivers them across a
busy highway following this Damen goes
to Agata to share his findings but the
latter is unwilling to hear him at all
as a result he walks away but not before
covertly stealing her copy of the
school's keys at midnight Damian sneaks
into the school and makes his way to the
chemistry lab while hiding from the
patrolling security guards once there he
discovers concrete evidence confirming
the on-site production of drugs suddenly
he hears approaching footsteps prompting
him to hide behind a cylinder he then
sees the chemistry professor Stefan
entering the room revealing that he is
the manager of the drug manufacturing
process he's like a budget ass
Heisenberg once Theon exits Damen
follows him and Witnesses security
guards loading the produced drugs into a
delivery van he captures some pictures
before tailing the van eventually
arriving at a secret Warehouse there
he's spotted by some guards so he
engages in a fight and overpowers them
with their own weapons the following day
Damen shows the picture to leac and AATA
who still remain unconvinced due to the
blurry nature of the photographs
nonetheless the principal summoned
Stefan and chamski to confirm this
Stefan contends that he was working late
on an experiment for class and the
security team helped him in cleanup
hearing this the principal dismisses
daman's claim deeming it as a
misunderstanding even though the
experiment was drugs meanwhile Agata
visits Amelia's house to uncover the
actual truth she knows that something is
really wrong the teenager who is
overwhelmed with guilt ends up
confessing everything meanwhile Damen
reviews the school security camera
footage and realizes that it's all been
tampered with he now starts breaking
down as he feels that he's failing in
his mission shortly after he is visited
by Agata who apologizes to him for not
trusting him earlier it is at this
moment that he shares everything about
about himself including his past
profession and the reason why he's doing
so upon understanding his perspective
Agata decides to assist him and they
also share a reconciling kiss they then
go to confront Stefon demanding to
reveal everything he knows but before he
can disclose anything chamski arrives on
his motorcycle and shoots the chemist
dead more of a Gabe than a Heisenberg
the next day the principal instructs
Agata to clean out Simon's Locker while
he goes to meet Amelia who is there to
to confess in the locker Agata finds a
hidden notebook containing a map
pinpointing the exact location of drugs
within a secret Warehouse later on
daman's students return to the dojo and
reunite with them after learning the
truth from Amelia however their joyous
reunion is interrupted when Damian
receives a call from Agata informing him
of an attack on Amelia that has led her
to a coma upon reaching the hospital she
shows him Simon's notebook and the two
decide to investigate the warehouse
unbeknownst to them she milski still has
his eyes on their actions upon arriving
at the mentioned location they uncover a
stash of illegal drugs ready for
distribution not long after they're
surrounded by chamski his associates as
well as leac who is finally revealed as
The Mastermind behind all of this
shocked Agata inquires for the reason
why he's doing so to which the principal
explains that he has given up on the
current generation of students who don't
value education that's why he's giving
them what they want drugs he then orders
his men to finish off the duo but just
before that Camille and the entire class
show up to help their teacher in
defeating the drug dealers the fight
ensues between the two parties the
students charge on Yaro and the other
henchmen while Damien goes after chamski
being a professional fighter Damen gains
the upper hand against chamski and
eventually kills him after this he
rushes out looking for Agata and finds
her in Lex's custody the principal holds
her at gunpoint threatening to comply
but Damen attacks him anyway he takes no
time to knock him down to the ground
believing that the threat has been
neutralized Daman turns his attention to
Agata only to be proven wrong leac gets
up retrieves another firearm from his
sock and shoots Damian in his shoulder
but before he fires the second shot
Camille shows up in a crane and pours a
container of toys on leac incapacitating
him and finally exacting revenge for his
father in the aftermath the police
arrive at the scene and apprehend the
actual culprits thereby vindicating
Simon's name from the criminal
accusations subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching